Destructuring also works with
arrays of...first a joke. Why
did the developer leave his job?
Because he wanted "arrays."
Terrible. Now we
need to talk about destructuring
with arrays. Sometimes you have
some data where it's based on
its index value. You want to get
the first, the second and the
third thing out. Where you
might be able to say 'const name =
details', so the first one. You
could say 'const', the D is 'details'
. The second one, you get the
point what I'm doing here.
That's no way to live your life.
What we can do is use
destructuring, where we can say 'const'
, and instead of using curly
brackets -- because when you
pull from an object, you use
curly brackets to destructure.
When you pull from an array, you
use square brackets to
destructure. Similarly,
we're going to learn about maps
and sets. When you pull from a
map, you'll use curly brackets.
When you pull from a set, you'll
use square brackets. We will
say ' = details'
. That's just going to take the
first, the second, and the third
thing, and make us a whole bunch
of variables. 'Console.log(
name, ID, website)', see what we
got, "Wes Bos 1 2 3 wesbos.
com" Cool. That is very helpful
when you have index-based stuff.
It could also be helpful when
you have a comma-separated list
or string. Let's say we're given
some data in a string that looks
like this. We have 'Basketball',
'Sports', '90201' and '23'.
That's the item name, the item
category, the item SKU, and the
item inventory left on hand. You
say, "Thanks for the data, but
that's just a string. That's not
really helping me out." We do
know that one thing that we can
do if the data is perfectly
separated by some sort of
separator is we could say data.
split it based on some sort of
splitter, right here. Then
we've got a good array here.
Then you know that you can also
destructure an array. Let's say 'const'
, let's just destructure that
baby right away. '
=
data.split'. Why? This is going
to return in array right here,
and then just immediately we're
going to destructure that array
into its own four variables that
we have here. If I console
log those variable, we should
see "Basketball Sports 90210 23".
Good. I'm really happy with that.
One question, though, is what
happens if the data is not great,
and you have some extra stuff on
here, like 'Wes' and 'Bos' and 'cool'
? Three extra items, what
happens to them when you
destructure something that is
not the same length as the
actual array? Well, nothing
happens, because it will just
throw those extra ones out.
Watch, if I go ahead and console
log all of these again, you'll
see that they still work. Then
there are not variables to get
these last ones, because I did
not destructure them. Sometimes
you do want to get the rest of
them. I say "the rest" of them,
because there's this thing in
ES6. We're going to learn a
little bit more about in a
future video. There is a helpful
use case in destructuring with
using the rest. Let's say I have
a team, and I want to know who's
the captain, who's he assisting
captain, and who is the rest of
the actual team? I'm going to
make myself a quick array here.
I've got a list of names here. 'Wes'
is the 'captain', 'Harry' is
the 'assistant captain', and
then the rest of the team is
just going to be part of the
team. How would you destructure
that into Captain, Harry and
then the rest? We say 'const
', and
then we do... Ideally you
want to say team. Let's just do
that ' = team', or not team. I
already used that variable.
We'll call them ' =
team. Let's see what that gives
us. "Captain is Wes." Assistant
is not defined because I don't
know how to spell assistant...is
Harry. Then what are 'players'? "
Sarah". 'Sara' is not the only 'player'
, there's also 'Keegan' and 'Riker'
. How would we get them on?
We use what's called the 'rest
operator', and it does exactly
what it says. It just gives you
the rest of them. Let's take a
look now. Where's 'players'? 'Players'
is an array of whatever's left.
Sometimes you want to grab the
first, the second, and the third,
and then you just want to bundle
whatever else is on the end of
that array into the rest of the
array. That is where you can use
the 'rest operator'. We're
going to talk much more about
this. You probably may also have
heard of this 'spread operator'
which looks exactly the same.
We'll dive into that in future
videos.